vous
a senti seul
vous avez vous déjà aussi prise au pied
moi ça m'est arrivé
et je ne parle pas de maintenant
présidé une conférence ted sedan
cependant connu en se disant pourquoi
j'ai fait ça non
je parle d'une longue aventure amené
à votre avis quel est le pourcentage noé
femmes en france souffrent de maladies
rares
et bien sûr avantage ces 4 %
4 300 en fait c'est énorme
se voudrait dire que parmi vous le
public rai douze personnes attendues de
ces conditions
donc maintenant pour ya deux ans un tour
si ce n'est pas vous c'est peut être
votre voisin où ça concerne personne que
vous connaissez comme un ami un membre
de votre famille ou encore une personne
que vous aimez
et si vous personnellement vous pouviez
faire quelque chose
si vous pouviez avec les deux ans vous
battre contre ces maladies rares le
feriez vous
j'aimerais à introduire une maladie une
semmadi rare qu'on appelle le déficit en
facteur 5 congénitale
c'est la conte qui vu son nom mais cet
om a dit génétique qui provoque chez ses
passions des saignements plus abondants
et sévère que la normale elle est causée
par une mutation dans un gène appelé f5
qui commet une protéine appelée facteur
de coagulation 5 qui dans ce cas
manquantes ou presque
sa cause donc l'apparition de
saignements plus long chez les patients
parfois la suite de traumatismes de
chirurgie ou lors démonstration pour les
femmes
et il ya des décès en excès maladie
concerne par exemple des nourrissons
mais en général tous les âges ils sont
touchés
et même dans les cas plus modérée voire
mineurs like a été vite du patient peut
baisser à cauet saignements fréquents
qui veulent enterrer son quotidien
vous vous demandez peut-être commencer
tout ça mais surtout pourquoi
et en fait c'est beaucoup plus simple
j'ai dû coller cette maladie d'un niveau
du personnel
je connais expérience de simple
saignement de nez ou d'un petit accident
qui va très vite incontrôlable
parfois même je dois rester au lit
pendant quelques jours
à quoi ces saignements qui peuvent durer
une demi-heure une heure voire plus et
que durée du rythme et des semaines
entières
on pourra lancer dire qu' il existe
entre nos principes adoptés qui pourrait
au moins prévenir c'est lyon mais non
les seuls traitements disponibles font
en général des produits dérivés de don
de sang qui sont souvent inaccessibles
et peuvent causer plusieurs effets
secondaires
et pourtant c'est uma des génétique qui
est caractérisée depuis années 50
et depuis les innovations dans le
domaine de la biologie la médecine on
perdre la voie à de nouvelles thérapies
alors pourquoi cette maladie ne peut
toujours pas être traité
lui en fait c'est par ce biais que deux
personnes atteintes à meiser terre
2010le personnes ce n'est pas rien mais
ce n'est pas assez en termes d'études
marché s'était pas rentable en termes de
politique de santé
c'est négligeable et surtout pour les
chercheurs c'est énormément de temps de
ressources et d'efforts consacrés si on
veut découvrir un nouveau traitement
à 14 ans donc il ya deux ans après un
long mois ridley par ces saignements je
me suis dit
si personne ne peut faire pour l'instant
alors pourquoi pas moi
pourquoi ne pas au moins proposer une
idée intéressante et rationnelle posé la
première pierre d'un édifice qui
permettrait peut-être un jour de trouver
solution
alors voici mon plan on va parler de
quelques détails techniques
si vous êtes perdus ce n'est pas grave
j'étais aussi au début
en passant deux ans à utiliser ma
théologie et la biologie on peut
s'intéresser un thérapie prometteuse
c'est la thérapie par arn messager vous
la connaissez peut-être à cause des
vaccins contre 19 mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec notre sujet
notre cas c'est comme essayer
d'introduire un code dans une machine
afin que les cuts un objectif précis
le code c'est l'airé messager et
l'objectif c'est que le patient puisse à
nouveau voir dans son sens la protéine
factor 5 ans la produisant on va donc
combler son manque
on va donc essayer d'insérer les
messages écho dans le facteur 5 dont un
celui de passion mais puisque la rems
hec gradassi vie dans le corps on
enferme dans des très petites structures
circulaires qu'on appelle des
nanoparticules lipidique ses soucis vont
permettre à air et messagers de se
libérer dans l'essai du patient et qui
vont avec leur de leurs séquences
synthétiser à nouveau la prochaine
factor 5
en général la thérapie par un message
semble intéressante novatrices et
efficaces
selon certains insultent le scientifique
cependant c'est encore une technologie à
ses balbutiements il faudra énormément
dit pousser sur des animaux et celui du
mans afin de prouver son efficacité
ainsi que sa sûreté
il ya voiture ce moment où on peut le
faire grand chose
j'ai mon idée mais je dispose pas des
moyens financiers ou humains pour lancer
une scientifique
et si je construisais mon propre
laboratoire
j'avais
tête qui permettrait si tout se passe
bien de produire de l'adn chez moi on
pourra ensuite avec sa doyenne fabriquer
de l'arrêt message est précieuse
expérience ou tout simplement étudiées
le gène de la protéine est facteur 5 mai
un premier il faut un espace de travail
ils ont reconstruit et mieux pouvoir
qu'ils fabriquent toutes affichent de
laboratoire dans un garage entre des
planches de bois et quelques étagères
avec sur un table bancale à
l'électronique marche parce que plus
edwards et d'autres accessoires
indispensables laboratoire comme une
coupette ce n'est pas le bateau est là
pour faire quoi que ce soit mais on voit
ce qu'on dit et cela
dans mon cas je veux obtenir en grand
quantité laden genève 5
responsabilité c'est un facteur 5 chez
moi donc de adl fait maison et j'ai bien
essayé parce qu'il est tellement de
hauts et de bas ces périples que j'ai
fait à bonal et plusieurs fois en fait
j'ai essayé de cultiver des bactéries
très usant laboratoire qu'on appelle et
charrier shia colis hockey en injecter
de l'adn du jeune f5
si tout se passe bien les balles qu'on
cultive se multiplient il a dès qu'on a
trop joué avec aussi
en purifiant on obtient donc de grandes
quantités de yens qu'on pourra ensuite
utiliser pour de futures expériences et
avoir à cet adn est vital pour commencer
n'importe quelle expérience
malheureusement est ainsi passé comme
prévu
après avoir aussi des souches de baky et
d'un chercheur je suis au fait y
cultiver ont été posés sur une surface
j'ai tenus ce qu'on appelle un milieu de
culture lba gare la première déception
c'est de ne voir aucun bactéries poussé
après des jours d'attenté
normalement si tout se passe bien on
doit voir ça mais dans mon cas on ne
voyait rien du tout
et les échecs on s'enchaîner entre
l'apparition de champignons dans les
mairies culture l'action' laboratoire et
j'en passe ces défaites ne font au mieux
recommencer sauf que j'ai tant de mal à
finir
avec un peu plus de patience et de
rigueur si voici après quelques défaites
et surtout demeurer c'est un jour
presque agacé j'arrive enfin à voir des
baltes et réapparaître des colonies
entières qui grandissait qui se
multiplier
ça a marché
ça peut être d'un pour moi pour vous
mais c'est une étape qui de base inax il
un niveau
vous avez devant vous des bactéries qui
produisent qui cultivent de dn au fil du
temps
on pourra ensuite avec ça devienne
cultiver de les produire delà des reines
de la rn pour la suite des expériences
voilà c'était la première étape d'un
plan et les minimes et le compte pas
grand chose mais elle est achevée
c'était l'après en marche dans
l'escalier et j'ai réussi
l'expérience qu'ont donnés au moins
l'opportunité d'en savoir plus sur la
biologie mais surtout quand elle a
reculé on pourra par la suite étudié
l'efficacité de traitement sur des
cellules ou sur deux organismes encore
plus complexe mais cette fois ci dans un
mur en laboratoire le ster
il dézingue possible grâce aux avancées
technologiques notre époque de connaître
presque tout le savoir du monde
n'importe qui peut donc se lancer dans
les sciences de l'epan situe son savoir
pour le bien commun et j'ai contribué
dans provoqua
j'espère que tout ce travail fait et
surtout à venir permettra peut-être un
jour à ces quelques patients d'enfants
recevant un traitement adapté leurs
positions
nous ne sommes même pas au début cette
aventure lorsque l'échec est grand mais
peut-être qu'un jour ces personnes
pourront enfin volant vitres plus
gérable voire sauver et croyez moi qu'il
faudra moins de 4% à population pour y
arriver il faut juste la patience de la
volonté et quelques mains tendues pour
moi c'est marc pajot et et l'association
française des hémophiles le docteur
voyez les cristaux de l'inserm ainsi que
le docteur guérin white de l'institut
singer et j'aimerais conclure cette aide
le remerciant pour le coûte ainsi que
pour leurs élèves
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]